yes we are with four-time champ anna
zatonski anna it seems like it's been a
long time coming getting a win in this
tournament why is it so hard
our competition is getting stronger i'm
not getting younger and
i'm unfortunately i'm in a terrible form
here it's like probably my so far worst
tournament ever
i would say unfortunately in corona
times i have two kids and i was like
very busy
like in everyday needs and i completely
didn't study
didn't get ready for this one uh
this game tell us about it it looked
like you had a good position
pretty early on where was the mistake
actually i didn't understand why why he
gave she gave up opponent b7 why not 95.
all right
from the opening you had played 92
and no but i think after uh yes it's six
i don't like your six move yes
65 strategically i have very good
chances after this right right so
already she was in trouble allowing this
move yes he fights i was thinking i was
thinking to play five for instead of
castle was also interesting maybe just
transposition just to get it and then
once you got this position it looked
very good for you and now you're saying
there was a moment when she gave up the
pawn on b7 which we can rush right to
here so yes oh it was a mistake knight
knight xb7 is a mistake the computer has
uh very high standards okay
okay my second choice was queen c5 for
what but why why why not
uh i think he wanted to go uh rook to b1
and take on b7 with the route we just
maybe this
it maybe it was is better it thinks if
you don't play its move it's best move
it doesn't like you and it's going to
evaluate really bad no but after after
knight takes b7 i think my position is
very good right yes of course yes of
course still don't don't look at those
uh don't look at those evaluations
and uh and then you just got a good
position and
it didn't look like she had much of a
chance especially here down upon yeah
and i'm very happy that i was not in the
time pressure okay
a little bit
just two minutes was
just worse
and like very happy with my time
management by the end of the game
uh there was a very dynamic moment in
the game
that we're going to discuss with you as
we get to the very finish of this game
since you were waiting for so much right
here you did have a spectacular
combination the move
knight takes e6
was winning
beautifully did you notice
knight xc66 and uh
bishop takes bishop jackson roxy to what
no no work see it immediately wow
that's pretty yeah yeah it's very great
but i don't know like i was i was taught
her so if you have a chance to like uh
check mate or win a queen just to go go
[ __ ] with you
so i saw 94 is winning without
sacrificing anything that's what that's
the topic that we're actually going to
get into maybe you can join us for this
topic the idea of
aesthetics in chess versus practicality
magnus carson himself has said he
prefers to win without sacrificing but
now that you've seen the move knight
takes e6 and rook c8 versus your move
knight e4 which just basically forces
resignation
which one would you prefer to have
played or would you prefer what you did
or yeah i didn't see it because i didn't
look if i would didn't uh if i wouldn't
have knight e4 so maybe i would see this
combination
but now that you have seen it would you
have preferred to play it okay let me
take a look
again now here it is 96. no but i i can
i can tell you that i am in terrible
form in this tournament like michael q i
don't see board and don't know what
happened
and
right now i will go for practical i
would not go for sacrifice i wouldn't
risk it but like when i'm in normal my
in good shape and good form i will i
love also like some aesthetic it's
really cool i would go for this
all right 10 years ago
all right we have a win it looks like
for sam shanklin in that game wow so sam
coming back as well
all right we'll let you go uh before
before we let you go though now that you
have won
this game
do you feel like you're coming back a
little bit or you just
you know this is not like it looks like
your tournament yeah it's very difficult
difficult to say i think it's it's not
my tournament
it's very i don't know what's going on
it's just not me who is playing and i
don't have
okay i'm not feeling well this is one
explanation and
but still even if
in better condition i should play better
than i did no it's simply this blunders
so which which i did
it's
unacceptable for me
all right well we'll let you get some
rest and good luck tomorrow thank you
yes indeed good luck
anna